vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
porcentajes y de hecho pues vamos a
entrarle de una vez cuanto es a veces
por aquí cuánto es
a tomar el 15% de 40 el 15% de 40 y
bueno espero que tú ya sepas que
nosotros podemos convertir este
porcentaje en decimales simple y
sencillamente dividiendo 15 entre 100 y
si yo a esto lo multiplicó por 40 ya voy
a obtener el 15% de 40 entonces el 15%
lo podemos ver en su forma decimal como
punto 15 es decir 15 sobre 100 y si yo
lo que quiero tomarme es el 15% de 40
entonces tenemos que multiplicar a 40
por punto 15 y cuánto es esto
5 por 0 es 0 5 por 4 es 20 después hay
que poner un cero aquí abajo y me queda
uno por cero es 0 y 1 por 4 es 4 y ahora
hay que realizar la respectiva suma de 2
y 4 son 60 y 0 y no olvides recorrer el
punto tenemos que recorrer el punto de
dos lugares y entonces me va a quedar
justo aquí el punto decimal
16.00 es decir que el 15% de 40 es 6 y
espero no confundirte bastante porque
este es un problema bastante sencillo el
15% de 40 es 6 y ya con esto vamonos el
siguiente problema en el cual espero que
te confunda un poco más porque la idea
de este vídeo es que te sientas un poco
confundido con porcentajes y veas cómo
podemos resolver estos problemas cuál es
el punto 2
% el punto 2 % de 7 y bueno aquí hay que
tener cuidado el punto 2 % de 7 porque
si tú no piensas en un inicio y dices
pues si yo el punto 2 % lo veo en su
forma decimal informes y males punto 2
estás equivocado ya desde ahí tendrías
mala respuesta porque te estarías
olvidando de dividir entre 100 recuerda
que sea cual sea la cantidad que tenemos
en el porcentaje hay que dividirla entre
100 en este caso no quedaría punto 2
entre 100 o si multiplicamos por 10
tanto arriba como abajo me quedaría 2
entre 1000 esta es una forma de ver este
porcentaje si vemos puntos 2 % forma
decimal estos dos sobre 1000 o hay otra
forma mucho más sencilla de verlo lo que
hace es recorrer el punto decimal si
partimos del punto 2 % entonces hay que
recorrer el punto decimal 2 unidades
hacia la izquierda y voy a obtener punto
0 0 2 esta es su forma decimal y esto es
muy importante y sirve para cualquier
porcentaje tú te paras en donde está el
punto decimal y recorres el punto
decimal dos unidades de la izquierda y
con esto obtiene su valor decimal no te
vayas a ir con la finta de poner su
valor decimal tal cual porque entonces
cometería es un error muy bien entonces
ya tengo que quiero sacar el punto 2 %
de 7 y para esto hay que multiplicar a 7
por puntos 0 0 2 así que vamos a hacerlo
punto 0 0
2.002 ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por
7 y bueno esto está muy sencillo 7 por 2
es 14 entonces voy a poner el 14 aquí y
después lo que tengo que se ha de
recorrer el punto decimal tres lugares
hacia la izquierda donde está el punto
decimal de 14 hay que recorrerlo tres
lugares hacia la izquierda
entonces ya tengo aquí el 14
1 2 3 y el punto 0 14 entonces ya tengo
la respuesta el punto 2 % de 7 es puntos
0 14 y seguramente vamos a decir oye
pero es una cantidad bastante pequeña
estaremos bien y la respuesta es que si
tiene todo el sentido lógico del mundo
punto 2 por ciento es mucho menor que 1
% imagínate que cuando yo tomo el 1 por
ciento de 7 lo que estoy haciendo es
dividir a 7 en 100 partes y si yo quiero
el punto 2 % de 7 me tengo que tomar una
parte mucho más pequeña de hecho es como
dividir a 7 en 500 partes y tomarme
solamente una de estas 500 partes el
punto 2 por ciento es exactamente lo
mismo que 1 sobre 500 1 sobre 500 por 7
pues es una cantidad muy pequeña pero
bueno espero que este ejercicio te haya
confundido lo suficiente porque vamos a
ver otro ejercicio donde espero que te
confundas aún más recuerda que muchas
veces cuando nos confundimos podemos
matar las dudas así que fíjate muy bien
en este 4 es el 20% de qué
4 es el 20 de que el número y
seguramente tú puedes decir bueno voy a
tomarme al 20 por ciento en su forma
decimal que es punto 20 x 4 y ya está
pero estaría cometiendo un error si tú
multiplicas a 4 por punto 20 es lo que
estarías haciendo sacando el 20 por
ciento de 4 y no es lo que queremos
fíjate bien lo que dice la pregunta 4 es
el 20 por ciento de que el número así
que lo que vamos a hacer es fijarnos en
este número y por eso voy a llamar x a
este número al número que queremos
encontrar sea x el número si yo sé que 4
es el 20 por ciento de este número eso
quiere decir que 20 por ciento de x es
igual a 4 porque recuerda que x es el
número que estamos buscando y
seguramente ya se te prendió el foco es
guau estudiando reconozco esto lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera visto
en su forma decimal punto 20.2 fíjate
qué punto 20.12 es lo mismo punto 2 por
equis esto tiene que ser igual a 4
recuerda que si yo tengo un número le
quiero sacar el 20% lo multiplicó por
punto y ya sé que esto me tiene que dar
4 que el número es este y que crees ya
tenemos una ecuación lineal bien
sencilla de resolver para despejar a x
lo que quiere es dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre punto 2 esto entre
punto 2 eso entre punto 2 estos dos se
van desaparecen porque el punto 2.2 es 1
solamente me queda x y entonces obtengo
que x es igual a 4 entre punto 2 y
cuanto sexto punto 2 entre 4 aquí está
el punto decimal de 4 y bueno lo estoy
poniendo porque voy a recorrer el punto
decimal una vez hacia la derecha tanto
adentro como afuera para que se pueda
quitar el punto decimal que me estorba
aquí afuera de mi división y me queda 2
entre 44 entre punto 2 es exactamente lo
mismo que 40 entre 2 y bueno esta
división es muy sencilla 40 cuántas
veces caben dos buenos y esto lo hago en
dos y después cero es decir 20 veces 40
entre 12 20 ó 20 por 2 es igual a 40 y
por lo tanto x es igual a 20 y tiene
toda la lógica del mundo 4 es el 20 por
ciento de qué número pues el número es
porque porque si yo me fijo en el 20% el
20% es cómo dividir 20 entre 5 tomarme
un 20% es tomarme una quinta parte de
esta cantidad y la quinta parte de 20 es
44 por 5 a 20 pero si de todas maneras
no te queda claro o no me crees lo
puedes hacer por ti mismo puedes agarrar
el 20% de 20 es decir punto 2 por 20 y
vas a ver que te va a dar de respuesta a
4.2 por 20 esto es igual a 4 bueno
deberías intentarlo para ver que en
efecto llegamos a la misma respuesta
ahora bien déjame hacer otro ejercicio
el último ejercicio de este vídeo vamos
a hacer un ejercicio muy parecido al que
hicimos hace rato 3 es el 9 % voy a
decir que 3 es el 9% de que número de
que número y bueno de igual manera que
hicimos en el ejercicio pasado voy a
definir a x como el número el cual
cumple que 3 es un 9% cumple que 3
por ciento bueno ha dicho no tuve que
haber escrito todo esto pero ya tengo el
valor de x y como lo hicimos la vez
pasada dijimos punto 0 9 es decir el 9
por ciento de x esto sabemos que es
igual a 3 y voy a dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre puntos 0 9 y me queda
que x es igual a tres entre punto 0 9 y
cuánto es esto pues vamos a hacer punto
0 9 va a dividir a 3 aquí voy a poner un
punto decimal y varios ceros y voy a
recorrer el punto decimal dos veces
hacia la derecha 12 12 perfecto aquí
está en el punto decimal es decir que
tres entre puntos 09 es lo mismo que 300
entre 9 y 300 en 39 pues cuánto es 30
entre 9 es 33 por 9 27 y sobran 3 ya ha
visto el patrón bajemos el 0-3 otra vez
del problema de 27 sobran 3 otra vez 3
otra vez 3 otra vez tres otra vez 3 así
hasta el infinito es decir que la
respuesta es
33.33 3333 o 33.3 periódico
es el 9 de 33.3 periódico o también lo
podemos ver en su forma de fracción 33
enteros un tercio porque recuerda que un
tercio es lo mismo qué punto 33 333 33
33 ambas son respuestas correctas ambas
respuestas están bien y de hecho con
bastante precisión no en todos los
ejercicios tienes que tener la mejor
precisión aunque en este ejercicio no
resuelto que teníamos bastante buena
precisión y bueno lo importante de todos
estos ejercicios que estoy haciendo es
que te des cuenta que hay una gran
diferencia dependiendo de lo que te diga
el problema el problema puede decir dos
cosas distintas si te piden el 10% de
100 pues eso es muy fácil solamente hay
que multiplicar 100 por punto 10 pero
recuerda que si te dicen el problema
contrario es decir 100 es el 10% de qué
cantidad bueno pues en ese momento hay
que aplicar las matemáticas y hay que
ser el álgebra y te va a dar de
resultado 1000 es pero no te confundas
bastante vamos a intentar hacer más
ejercicios de esto para que lo entiendas
perfectamente